erica is up first she is in Springfield
Missouri Erica you're on the Dave Ramsey
show how can we help hi thanks for
taking my call absolutely how do we help
well I'm calling to get your opinion on
something that my husband and I have
been on the fence about for quite a
while he's a doctor so he has really
high student love debt we're at about
three hundred and fifty thousand and we
have five kids and a college student
living with us in a house that we love
but we've been questioning whether or
not to sell it and downsize so that we
can get out of that faster ah Erica how
long have you and your husband been
kicking around this idea probably for
about two years okay and so why are you
all willing to sell it um I just I
really want to get out of that more than
I want this house work and I also kind
of love the house okay I heard you say
the home that we love I thought that was
cute I loved how you tried to add that
in there as if that's gonna give me to
switch up on there but hold on a second
Erica how much is your husband's income
right now what's the household income um
well his take-home pay is about two
hundred and fifty thousand a year okay
all right and these student loans have
been hanging around for how long
um let's see since about 2006 he
graduated okay all right so almost 10
years yes they've been hanging out and
you're tired of looking at him aren't
you oh definitely
absolutely and what are the ages of your
kids um they are 14 12 11 8 and 5 my
goodness you are busy and tired yes yes
and here's the deal so what does your
husband feel about the idea of selling
the home I think he's okay with it um
yeah he doesn't he doesn't really seem
to give me an answer either way when we
talk about it okay and what's the value
of the home right now just estimation um
estimated about five hundred thousand
okay and how
do you owe on it about 280 okay all
right so obviously on the topic of it
you've got some equity here right what
now here's what I would do whenever you
start to walk through and you start to
make these kind of big decisions I
always like to weigh the pros and the
cons and so what I would encourage you
all to do once you get all these kids in
bed I want you to have a date night
where you all have a serious
conversation and instead of us just
kicking this idea around for two years
what I want you all to do is make a list
of the pros and cons and then I want you
to do this whenever you're making a big
decision you want to take the right
amount of town time appropriate to the
size of the decision so what I want you
and your husband to do is over the
course of the next kind of 30 days have
this be a board meeting that you all are
addressing meaning looking at this and
and what's the pro of it obviously you
have some equity you don't have that
debt anymore but now where are you going
to go live right where can you go and
Erica I know you said you love the home
but it sounds like to me young lady that
you also love the idea of being
debt-free and especially with those kids
so do this have that meeting with your
husband sit down weigh the pros and cons
and as you all start to look at this I
promise you a decision will become very
very evident and Anthony when you're
doing decisions like this what you don't
want to do is rush right right right I
agree you know I was definitely say
Hogan at the very end of these 30 days
have one more day tonight
Erica and go out and say okay listen
this is what we've decided to do after
we look at everything and put it on
paper you know there's a quote proverbs
out there that says a man who is
enslaved to the compass has freedom to
the Seas so once you are write down
exactly your compass which direction
you're going no matter what happens you
stick with that and you get out of debt
because we heard it in her voice she
does not like waking up every single day
and seeing this debt but the only way
she's going to get out of it is like you
said hey sit down
map out what's the best direction once
you figure out that direction I want you
to stay with it and stay focused and go
after it I can tell you this ken
whenever you have somebody that's making
a really good income and they're way
over the average or median income yeah
okay the median income
to the US Census Bureau is hovering
around 53,000 so well above that yeah I
can tell you this guy's lifestyle is
probably well above that median as well
and so when you start to make good money
what you don't want to do is to get into
bigger habits that require you to spend
so a house is it's a place for the
family to live you all let's not get so
emotionally tied into this yeah where
our status comes based on the home or
any of these other things
now obviously you guys they can't go
live on a thousand square foot apartment
that's right they have 17 children I'm
sorry there were five of them right all
right and so you start to look at this
but could they downsize and go rent
somewhere right could they then you know
triple up on payments or throw a
majority of the 220,000 and equity
they'd have if they sold the home right
these are all things to really walk
through and don't just focus on what
you're giving up yeah focus on what
you're gaining oh that's it oh you say
that one more time whenever you make a
sacrifice don't focus on what you're
giving up focus on what you're gaining
and what I mean by that is with this
they made a sacrifice and given up the
home but they're gaining financial
traction yes and they're gaining a big
chunk knocked out on that student loan
debt and now his income is only going to
go up yeah right and so they're two
sides of that is an intense move to sell
it yes could they stay in it and get
serious about paying it off yeah yes yes
right paying off home and student loans
but either way I like it in her voice
and I love that they're talking about it
but after two years of discussion it's
time to make some changes is that big
right you and Dave say all the time that
that salary that he has two hundred
thousand that's a big shovel yeah so if
they take some of that equity yeah and
they make them rent for a couple units
and my goodness with this income they
can get back to where they are except
have all that peace and a lot more food
and everything for those kids hey listen
we know this the older those kids get
the more expensive they get yes I mean
that's a reality and there's nothing
wrong with coming back so you can move
for y'all absolute nothing wrong with
that or not at all hey you guys Rachael
Cruz here I hope you're enjoying the
Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the dayroom to
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you